winners not waiting on me to be ready
it's here what I need to do is get all
my jet fuel barrels get them over to the
fuel said to get filled get as many
pallets as I can and get those over by
my heat tank I need to get it where it
needs to live for the winter to make it
the easiest closest for me when the
conditions are brutally cold and
brutally dark it's gonna take a quick
look at my barrels
oh what a project for barrels go on a
pallet in order for me to have enough
fuel for the entire winter that's 48
barrels I have to individually look at
each barrel say yes or no to it see if
they're empty if they're not verified
what's in it check it out make sure
there's no holes even a pinhole leak
it's a protected ecosystem you can't
leak fuel out all over it's just not the
way it's done so I have to visually
inspect each year each barrel this is a
no bad ones are over here why are they
bad well this one has a hole in it this
one's beat up really dang bad it looks
like it's been that way for a while like
here's a ding but it's not a hole but if
I need 48 barrels
I've got it in 48 inspections you know
I'm getting colder am i well below zero
no but now is the time to get everything
where it needs to be I have to continue
my process on getting the barrels where
they need to live because overnight I
can drop below zero within a couple
weeks I'm gonna be dark I got 48 and
that are free of holes free of things
that'll compromise the integrity of the
barrel next step for me though for this
you have to work start pump and feel